we are extremely excited about our new
program in bilingual education
this is one of the few programs where
you can get a license in bilingual
education in nevada
so again we are extremely excited about
this
in a district where we have over 40
percent latino latinx
and a large majority of spanish speakers
in this valley
it's extremely important for people to
understand the power
of speaking two languages and also the
power that it provides for our children
in the valley who are english learners
and who are bilingual to have teachers
who are prepared
to use their language to support their
needs in the classroom
if you are a speaker of two languages
this is power
sometimes in the united states we hear
that there is no power in being
bilingual but having a program like this
really demonstrates the power also it
shows the academics
the way that you can excel academically
when you are able to use both languages
in the classroom
we have a lot of people who are spanish
speakers who might speak spanish
socially
but might not have the academic language
that they need and so this allows our
children to be able to
have that academic language that they
use in school in english and in spanish
our goal is to enroll 30 students by the
fall of 2021 into this program
so we're we're in in process of that
right now
we want to make sure that students are
provided an opportunity to actually get
out there in the community
and see the power of this tool in the
community and i think that's one of the
most important pieces
is the children the sooner we can get
students out there with children
the better and so that's one of the
things that we'll focus on in this
program
is bringing students in and constantly
examining the program and how well we're
doing and
what areas that we need to change our
focus is i mean transition or the types
of bilingual program models that exist
are part of the district so
our goal is to prepare teachers to
potentially be in what will be known as
a dual language bilingual classroom
in other words half of the day would be
in english and half of the day would be
in spanish
so our students will be prepared for
whatever program model that is
being used at the school whether it's
transitional or dual language
we do have two pathways we have a
heritage spanish speaker pathway
for students who may have been raised
speaking spanish and who just want to
improve their their spanish and english
and then we also have a
non-heritage pathway for students like
myself who may have learned spanish as a
second language
so is this degree is this the first
degree of its kind in
nevada or southern nevada we had this
program many years ago
and it was inactive for many years and
with our hsi grant we were able to
revive the program
everything we do in the school of ed is
a partnership with ccsd and i say that
because we have to place our students
into classrooms for student teaching
experiences and they're usually in ccsd
although we do have some that are with
private schools or charter schools as
well but yes
that's the foundation of everything we
do our partnerships the foundation of
our program is social justice
so our students are trained to work with
families and to allow students to
celebrate their families and their
culture when they come into the class if
you're interested in enrolling in our
program
feel free to contact us at 702
or you can email us at nsc.edu